sprechen wir über Sieger war Gabriel
ehemaliger Bundesvorsitzender der SPD
ex-vizekanzler und Ex-Außenminister und
er sorgt jetzt mit diesem Tweet hier für
Furore es geht um Katar ja die deutsche
Arroganz gegenüber Katar schreibt der
ist zum Co Punkt Punkt Punkt wie
vergesslich sind wir eigentlich
Homosexualität war bis 1994 in
Deutschland strafbar meine Mutter
brauchte noch die Erlaubnis des Ehemanns
um zu arbeiten und Gastarbeiter haben
wir beschissen behandelt und miserabel
untergebracht so sieht man Gabriel
Roller die Waldfee holla die Waldfee
darüber werden wir jetzt sprechen Peter
Ziele unser Chefreporter hier bei uns im
Studio schönen guten Tag dir Peter guten
Morgen dieser Vergleich der sorgt im
Moment für ziemlich Furore und große
Empörung was sagst du zu diesem
Vergleich in der ex-vizekanzler dort
anbringt es ist typisch Sigmar Gabriel
neigt zu eruptiven Ausbrüchen und wenn
die dann mal raus sind sind sie nicht
mehr einzufangen es ist einfach
schändlich also sieht man Gabi vorher
noch also der letzte Tweet vor seinem
katarausbruch es waren Delfine die er
fotografiert hat vom Bord einer
Segelyacht an der türkischen
griechischen in den türkischen
griechischen Gewässern wir geschrieben
hat und das ist wirklich ein Hammer wenn
man das mal auseinander nimmt was er da
gibt da geschrieben hat natürlich warum
muss Sexualität bis in die 70er Jahre
rein oder bis in die 90er Jahre rein
jedoch in dem welchen Teil Deutschlands
mal aufgewachsen ist strafbar aber sind
die uns umgebracht worden sind die bei
uns ins Gefängnis gekommen was ist da
passiert was vergleicht Sigmar Gabriel
da womit das geht alles überhaupt nicht
und dann muss man natürlich wissen warum
macht er das ja warum macht er das
ein Verdacht liegt sehr nahe Sigmar
Gabriel sitzt im Aufsichtsrat der
Deutschen Bank und da sitzt nicht
reingerufen von der Deutschen Bank auch
nicht von der Sparkasse Stiftung oder
von irgendjemand anders sondern von
Überraschung Katar von dem Emirat von
dem blutscheichs über sie mal genannt
haben jetzt kriegen wir ja von in Öl
jetzt sind sie ein bisschen besser
irgendwas in öffentlichen Wahrnehmung
aber von den Blue Chicks ist er da
reingeschickt worden und Sigmar Gabriel
spricht hier nicht für sich Sigmar Gabi
spricht nicht für Deutschland Sigmar
hier spricht für Katar ganz
offensichtlich zumindest nicht der
Verdacht nahe und damit in einer schönen
Tradition komisch das erinnert mich
jetzt ganz merkwürdigerweise an einen
anderen großen SPD-Mann der mal Kanzler
war in Deutschland Gerd Schröder
komische Nähe plötzlich zu den Russen zu
Gast Brom und irgendwie hatte man
plötzlich das Gefühl was erzählt mich
mein Geschwätz von gestern jetzt bin ich
immer schön auf der russischen Seite was
ist los mit der SPD irgendwie so eine
merkwürdige Nähe zu des Guten plötzlich
also Schröder hat die Nähe ja schon als
Kanzler gehabt als Kanzler ja zwei
Kinder adoptiert von einer fremden Macht
also aus Russland man hat sich sehr
schön verstanden wie man hier irgendwie
sieht also beste Freunde schon zu
kanzlerzeiten aber wir müssen
tatsächlich mal so ein paar SPD
Vorsitzende durchgehen ich weiß nicht ob
was vorliegen haben aber Gerhard
Schröder natürlich Gas geben wie wir ihn
nennen und zwar völlig zu Recht wir
könnten ihn auch den ölprinzip von
Wladimir putinen bei deiner Gasfirma und
in der Ölfirma arbeitet aber dann haben
wir ja zum Beispiel noch so andere
ehemalige SPD-Vorsitzende wie zum
Beispiel Matthias Platzek den ich nur
wirklich seit über 30 Jahren kenne und
der ist bei mir nur Moskau Matze und
schon relativ lang auch als er noch
Ministerpräsident in Brandenburg war
auffällige Nähe aber zu zu
Moskau gehabt sehr viele Dienstreisen
dahin gemacht und wirklich Distanz los
und bis heute quasi so der der chronisch
meist der SPD also soweit wie Sabine
grundschmalz also wirklich jemand der
Propaganda gemacht hat oder gucken wir
uns mal Rudolf Scharping an wer kann
sich noch erinnern Rudolf Scharping
jetzt nicht große Russland Nähe aber der
Name gibt es schon her Rudolf Scharping
der macht
seit 15 Jahren lobbyiert Rudolf
Scharping der ehemalige SPD-Chef für
China und zwar relativ unverfroren mit
einer Beratungsgesellschaft und so kann
man durchgehen und wir können jetzt nur
hoffen dass ich unser aktueller
Bundeskanzler fängt und nicht in die
Geschichte eingeht auch als Chinas
Hafenmeister und hätten wir moskauplätze
rudolfing und dann noch den Hafenmeister
Olaf Scholz zu dumm der ist ja auf dem
besten Weg dahin ja warten wir mal ab
vielleicht fängt er sich ja irgendwie
noch vielleicht was eine Altlast hier
noch im Keller hatte und ja noch ganz
schnell durchbringen musste Hoffnung ist
noch aber kein gutes Bild dass die SPD
da abgibt mit ihrem Personal und muss
der Fairness halber sagen es gibt
Lobbyisten für drecksstaaten auch in
anderen Parteien aber halt besonders
auffällig wird die SPD mit ihrem spitzen
Personal jetzt Sigmar Gabriel wir sind
die Reaktionen seitens der SPD auf die
Äußerung von Sigmar Gabriel gibt es da
irgendwelche kritischen es ist Kommando
Tauchstation man möchte sich dazu nicht
äußern wenn man dazu etwas öffentlich
sagt kommt man mit in den Strudel rein
lassen Sie die mal machen sagen sie aber
sie haben ihn nun mal in der an Galerie
hängen und da hängt er halt niemand
Schröder und niemand schaping und neben
anderen Gestalten die nicht gerade
dadurch aufgefallen sind dass sie große
Distanz zu nicht zu angenehmen
Diktaturen haben man reiht sich an
Dankeschön Peter Titel für Einschätzung
[Musik]